good morning Hank it's Tuesday I don't
know what today's video is about I'm on
a social media hiatus right now it turns
out it's very difficult for me to hide
from social media but I'm on the hiatus
to write a book like I've been working
on a novel for the last four years but
I'm trying to like take the quotation
marks out of that working but like when
I'm really into a story it's hard to
think about anything else so I'm just
like sitting here thinking about things
that I can't tell you about anyway I
think it's going well but who knows I've
been wrong before I know there are
things I'm supposed to talk about
they'll write nerdcon Hank nerdcon
stories is just like a week and a half
away in the beautiful city of
Minneapolis there's a great bunch of
storytellers coming but the relevant
thing here Hank is that somehow or
another I agreed to a race car race with
my friend Maggie you know Maggie
stevedore stylet her stream water you
know Maggie who wrote all of those great
books apparently is Steve honor Steve
like the name honor like the mammal so
separate from nerdcon she and I are
going to be racing in actual race cars
on an actual racecar track on October
9th at 7:30 at Princeton Speedway
outside of Minneapolis it's 5 bucks at
the door all the proceeds go to this
charity drivers edge I have to wear like
a helmet and a fire suit in case my car
catches on fire and I'm going to lose
also there's blowing water on Mars
occasionally apparently and this very
exciting and the slide show people got
so excited they made like shirts and
posters I think I feel like Area C very
happy for you whenever there's big Mars
news like this but you know what's so
exciting that we haven't taken a second
to just be psyched about lately flowing
water on Earth earth man what a planet
say it says I should show you how my
tattoo is doing so I'm gonna do that now
don't get alarmed I'm just you know
taking off my shirt still there a little
bit welts all over the wall like some
people were complaining about the blank
blue wall that I finally put up my wall
stuff we got Woody Guthrie and his
guitar a big Willie and a medium sized
me and a puppy sized elephant to this
weird card someone sent me of Hank
humping peeps See's Yoshi tubman our
figures were edited by Sarah for my
birthday back in 2007 and speaking of
the Yeti there's one as well as in this
printed business card and brotherhood
2.0 resident mathematician Daniel Biss
his original paper about how circles are
really just bloated triangles I was just
thinking that a lot of this seems weird
if you haven't watched every
vlogbrothers video but then it occurred
to me that it also seems weird if you
have I hurt my nerdfighting peeps and
then of course we've got the Swindon
Town FA Cup championship from 2011
Abraham Lincoln a black Santa a road map
with agloe New York on it the beer sword
you
drawing of Willie nerd fight astok shoes
Chewbacca
dftba ducky and an imperial affliction
which I stole from the movie set then we
got some willies and puppy-sized
elephants and French llamas and st.
Francis of Assisi I'm not really sure
what he's doing there it's just a
starting but I think it looks pretty
good nerdfighters let me know what I'm
missing in comments so Hank I was just
violating my social media hiatus by
looking at Twitter to see if there's
anything else I should talk about and it
turns out that in the last hour you've
launched a new company Hank you amazed
me that's not a compliment exactly it's
just an observation so hey dftba games
which you co-founded has just launched a
Kickstarter for its first game wizard
school it's a card game that hones one's
wizard education skills while one waits
for one's letter from Hogwarts which one
hasn't totally given up on even though
one is technically 38 years old I for
one am excited in fact I was one of your
first 10 backers Yeti and I are huge
nerds for tabletop card games Hank so
this is very exciting for us ok Hank I'm
gonna go back to working on the story
now hopefully I'll be able to report
real progress on a real book soon Hank I
will see you on Friday